نابلس المحلل والخبير في الشان الاسرائيلي
السيد سليمان بشرات سيد سليمان اولا ماذا
قرات في البيان المشترك لجانس جالانت
ونتنياهو تعقيبا على الحادثه التي حصلت في
المغازي وسقوط 21
قتيلا من ضباط وجنود جيش
الاحتلال نعم تحيه لك جلال وتحيه لمتابعي
الكرام اقرا هناك مقاربتين اساسيتان لرده
فعل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فيما يتعلق بهذه
الحادثه الاولى وهي المقاربه الجمعيه او
الجماعيه وهيي انعكست في البيان المشترك
الذي تحدث عنه نتنياهو وجلن وجانتس وهذه
ربما محاوله امتصاص للصدمه الكبيره
والمباشره على المجتمع الاسرائيلي وعلى
المنظومه الامنيه والعسكريه وبالتالي هم
لا يريدوا ان يحدث هناك نوع من الانهيار
الداخلي للمجتمع الاسرائيلي عندما نتحدث
ان اليوم نحن في اليوم ال9 لهذه الحرب
وبالتالي هم يريدون ان يبقوا حاله من
تماسك شرائح المجتمع الاسرائيلي ولهذا
السبب ظهر اولا بيانا مشتركا وليس بيانا
منفردا حتى يدلل على حاله التماسك وايضا
ارادوا ان يركزوا على الهدف الاساس
لاستمراريه الحرب وبالتالي وكانهم يريدوا
ان يوصلوا رساله للمجتمع الاسرائيلي
داخليا ان هناك توافقا داخليا وليس كما
كان الحال في في الايام والاسابيع الماضيه
ان هناك خلافا لدى مجلس الحرب الداخلي
المقاربه الثانيه وهي ربما هذه التي تهمنا
التي ربما ستكون لها تداعيات في الايام
المقبله وليس الان وهي المقاربه الجزئيه
التي تتعلق في العلاقه التي ستربط ما بين
المستوى السياسي ومجلس الحرب بداخله اولا
وثانيا في العلاقه ما بين المستوى السياسي
والمستوى العسكري عندما نتحدث الان عن عن
حدث كهذا كهذا وبحجم هذا المستوى وهذا
الخسائر ربما يكون له تداعيات وربما يكون
له اتهامات واتهامات مضاده ما بين كيف
يترك الجيش على مدار هذا الوقت في ظل وجود
في في ظل عدم وجود اهداف سياسيه محدده
لاستمراريه الحرب وكيف يمكن ان ان ان
يستطيع الجيش الاسرائيلي ان يحقق الاهداف
الاهداف السياسيه الغير واضحه لاستمراريه
هذهه العمليه وبالتالي انا باعتقادي الان
هذه الحادثه ربما ستكون مفصليه ولكن
تداعياتها كما قلت لن تكون الان ظاهريه في
هذه المرحله وربما في الايام المقب انت
قلت سيد سليمان انه بالشكل يبدو بانها
محاول ولا لعدم انهيار المجتمع الاسرائيلي
الى اي مدى المجتمع الاسرائيلي قب قوسين
او ادنى من هذا الانهيار الذي تتحدث عنه
في ظل الخسائر اليوميه عدم تحقيق الاهداف
وعدم رؤيه واضحه لهذه الحرب وما
بعدها نعم هذه نقطه مهمه وحساسه
وبالمناسبه يعني تابعنا خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه كيف ان المجتمع الاسرائيلي بدات
تزداد مساحه وساحه الانتقاد اولا لاداره
الحرب من جانب ومن جانب اخر لقدره هذه
الحرب واستمراريتها على تحقيق الاهداف
الاهداف التي وضعت في بدايه الحرب وتم
تعبئه المجتمع الاسرائيلي خلفها وهي اهداف
تتعلق اولا باعاده الاسرى من ارض المعركه
من جانب ومن جانب اخر القضاء على المقاومه
الفلسطينيه الان الهدفان هذين الهدفين لم
يتحققا على الرغم من الذهاب الى الى طول
هذه الحرب من من حيث البعد الزماني وايضا
من حيث القدره على تحقيق هذه الاهداف في
اعاده اي من الاسرى داخل قطاع غز اذا هنا
ربما يبدا المجتمع الاسرائيلي وبالتحديد
الشارع الاسرائيلي تتبلور اكثر المواقف في
الذهاب اما الضغط اكثر باتجاه المستوى
السياسي بشكل مباشر الى الذهاب الى وضع
اهداف واقعيه يمكن تحقيقها اولا وثانيا
قياس الاهداف وتحققها بقياس طبيعه وحجم
الخسائر عندما نتحدث اليوم عن
يعني ضابطا وجنديا سق فقط في الحرب نحن
نتحدث الان عن قرابه
220 في في صفوف الجيش منذ بدايه الحرب
البريه واكثر من خ 500 منذ السابع من
اكتوبر هذا الرقم كبير جدا في حجم الخسائر
في المفهوم المجتمعي داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي هذا سيطرح سؤالا
اساسيا وهو طبيعه الثمن الذي يجب ان يدفع
في سبيل تحقيق هذه الاهداف وهي ما زالت
اهداف حتى هذه اللحظه غير
قابله للتحقيق او القياس سي سليمان يفترض
باي عمليه عسكريه ان تحقق الاهداف
السياسيه هل ينطبق هذا على استراتيجيه
بنيامين نتنياهو في التعامل مع الحرب على
غزه نعم وهذه النقطه المهمه الحرب دائما
هي تعتبر اداه من ادوات السياسه او لتحقيق
الاهداف السياسيه كما قلنا وهذا ربما ظهر
في في الاسبوعين الماضيين عندما خاطبت
هيئه الاركان الاسرائيليه للجيش
الاسرائيلي خاطبت المستوى السياسي وقالت
اننا في الاهداف التي يمكن تحقيقها او او
ما اسماها في ذلك الوقت هليفي بالانجازات
الميدانيه للجيش الاسرائيلي حتى هذه
اللحظه لا يوجد تصورا على المستوى السياسي
لاستثمار هذه الانجازات وبالتالي هنا انا
باعتقادي هذا ربما ما سيشعل النقاش داخل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي وما بين الجيش
والمستوى السياسي خلال الايام المقبله انه
كيف يمكن ان يتم تحويل الانجازات ما بين
قوسين الى اهداف سياسيه يتم تحقيقها
واستثمارها على المستوى العمليات على
الارض اولا ومن ثم تحقيقها او انعكاسها
على المستوى السياسي انا باعتقادي حتى هذه
اللحظه هناك خلاف كبير جدا ما بين الذهاب
او تقليص الاهداف في نظر بنيامين نتنياهو
وهذا المنظور الذي بات ينتقد به المجتمع
الاسرائيلي والكثير من الكتاب والكثير من
القاده ان بنيا ميد نتنياهو يريد ان
يستثمر كل ذلك للاهداف الشخصيه به
ومستقبله السياسي وليست للاهداف الكليه
التي تتعلق بمفهوم الدوله ولهذا السبب انا
باعتقادي هنا ستكون هنا النقاش الاكبر
وهنا الانتقادات الاكبر وهنا السؤال الذي
سيطرح بشكل كبير جدا على بنيامين نتنياهو
كل هذه التضحيات من المجتمع الاسرائيلي وم
ومن الجيش الاسرائيلي هل هي ستعود فعلا
باهداف تتعلق بمفهوم الدوله ولهذا السبب
اذا ما لاحظنا الخطاب اليوم كان من جنت
ومن بنيامين نتنياهو يتحدث عن المفهوم
الوجودي وكانهم يريد ان يعيدوا المجتمع
الاسرائيلي الى حاله التحضير الاساسيه
لهذه الحرب عندما يتحدث عن مستقبل الدوله
وليست الاهداف الاساسيه او الاهداف
الشخصيه بشخصياتهم لكن سرعان ما هذه
الروايه ستعيد مره اخرى القراءه التي
تبناها بنيامين نتنياهو خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه انه يتحدث عن اهداف من منطلقات
ورؤى شخصيه وليست من منطلقات الدوله
ومستقبل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي طيب
ا فيما يتعلق
بالصفقات سيد سليمان الى ماذا يسعى بنم
نتنياهو برفض الصفقه تلو الاخرى ودائما
يشدد هو وقياده ايضا مجلس الحرب على ما
يقولون بانه القضاء على حماس في هذه الحرب
واسترجاع المحتجزين الى ماذا يسعى في هذه
الاستراتيجيه وا اغلاق اي باب للتفاوض
وعوده المحتجزين
بتقديرك نعم هو يسعى الى امرين الاول هو
اطاله امد هذه الحرب لهذا السبب هو يرغب
في ان يكون هناك حاله من تجزئه اي صفقات
او اي اطروحات يتم الحديث عنها ولا يريد
ان يذهب الى صف شامله يمكن لها ان تنهي
الحرب بالمقياس الزمني وهذا هو ربما مطلب
المقاومه الفلسطينيه انها وضعت شرطا
اساسيا لاي صفقه مقبله ان ي ان تقوم باساس
وقف لهذه الحرب وهذا لا يريده بنيامين
نتنياهو لاننا نعلم بشكل كبير جدا ان
اطاله امد الحرب هي تمثل طوق النجاء
لبنيامين نتنياهو النقطه الاخرى وهي ان
بنيامين نتنياهو يريد ان يدير الخلافات
الداخليه بما يحقق له انه هو الشخص القادر
على اداره هذه الخلافات ويحقق الاهداف
الاساسيه بنيامين نتنياهو يتغذى على
الخلافات الداخليه ويحولها الى فرص ليظهر
انه الشخص الاكثر قياده لاسرائيل في هذه
المرحله العصيبه كما يسميها من جانب ومن
جانب اخر يريد ان يظهر كل المنافسين له في
اداره الحرب على انهم غير قادرين على
النهوض او الاستمراريه في تحدي او اجتياز
التحديات التي تواجه اسرائيل وبالتالي بن
نتنياهو ما زال يراهن على قدراته الشخصيه
وعلى مهاراته الذاتيه في اداره هذه الحرب
ويريد بكل ذلك ان يحول كل هذه النقاط الى
نقاط فرص بالنسبه له يستثمرها لبعده
السياسي اولا ولبرنامج
الانتخابي ثانيا ورؤيته ومنظوره المستقبلي
فيما يتعلق بتحقيق ضمان مستقبله السياسي
لاسرائيل طيب ايه لفتنا بالبيان المشترك
لنتنياهو جانت و جلانس ايه ما قالوا بانهم
لن يتوقفوا عن السعي لتحقيق الانتصار اولا
كيف كيف تفهم السعي لتحقيق الانتصار بعد
ان كان الحديث عن بان الانتصار سيتحقق
والقضاء على حماس سيتحقق والسيطره على غزه
لفتره طويله اولا وهذه الاستراتيجيه هل
ممكن ان توصل اسرائيل بقيادتها الحاليه
الى ما تسميه
الانتصار نعم هذا هدف سياسيا هو هدف ضبابي
ويمكن ان يفسر من قبل اي طرف من الاطراف
بما فيهم بنيامين نتنياهو او اي عضو في
اعضاء مجلس الحرب او حتى المجتمع
الاسرائيلي وتقديمه على انه في اي مرحله
من المحطات التي يرى فيها الفرصه سواء
مجلس الحرب او بنيامين نتنياهو انها تحصلت
يمكن ان يفسر له الانتصار باي طريقه ما
وهذا بالمناسبه اذا عدنا الى طريقه تقديم
وتفسير بنيامين نتنياهو للمحطات لمحطات
الهدن التي جرت خلال هذه الحرب والافراج
عندما قال اننا امام قرار صعب ولكن هذا
القرار الصعب هو لصالح اعاده ابنائنا هذا
كان جزءا من تفسير انه هو جزء من الانتصار
او تحقيق الاهداف و وبالتالي بنيامين
نتنياهو هو الان لا يريد ان يضع نفسه في
وضع يمكن ان يقدم هدفا لا يمكن تحقيقه
وبالتالي هو يذهب الى هذا التعميم وهذا
بالمناسبه هو هدف بات الجميع داخل مجلس
الحرب يقدمونه للمجتمع الاسرائيلي لا يقدم
لا يريد ان يقدموا هدفا واضح المعالم حتى
لا يحاسبوا عليه بشكل اساس هذا من جانب
الجانب الاخر هدف الانتصار بالنسبه لكافه
اركان يعني اعضاء الحرب الاسرائيليه او
مجلس الحرب الاس اسرائيلي هو ايضا يساعدهم
في في في في طبيعه الخطاب الذي يوجه اولا
الى المجتمع الاسرائيلي الداخلي ومن ثم
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي تمثل
هي حليفا وداعما لهذه الحرب من جانب ومن
جانب اخر ايضا هي تضغط على مجلس الحرب
للذهاب الى تحديد رؤى واقعيه فيما يتعلق
بمجريات هذه الحرب ومستقبل هذه الحرب
وبالتالي كل منهما وبالتحديد مجلس الحرب
اولا بشكل مجتمع ومن ثم داخل مجلس الحرب
كل منهما ي يحاول ان يقدم رؤيته بما يحقق
له ان يكون هناك طوق نجاه في المستقبل وان
لا يتحمل المسؤوليه الخالصه وهذا
بالمناسبه احد الاشكاليات التي يعاني منها
الان مجلس الحرب هم لا يريد اي منهم اي
منهما ان يتخذ قرارا يتحمل به تبعات هذا
القرار يريد كل منهما ان ينتظر اخطاء
الطرف الاخر او شق الاخر من داخل مجلس
الحرب حتى يتحمل مسؤوليه اي فشل ممكن او
اي ثمن يمكن ان يدفع
في الحلبه السياسيه المستقبل سيد سليمان
امام ما سماه البيان السعي لتحقيق
الانتصار وهو لم يتحقق حتى الساعه بعد
مرور 100 و 108 ايام في ظل الضغوط
الامريكيه خاصه والاقليميه للتوصل الى
صفقه جديده لتبادل الاسرى بالمحتجزين الى
اي مدى يستطيع نتنياهو ان يواجه هذه
الضغوط الداخليه والخارجيه في هذا
السياق نعم هو مازال حتى هذه اللحظه يعتمد
على قضيتين اساسيتين كما قلت اولا قدرته
على اداره الخلافات الداخليه وتحويلها الى
فرص استثماريه بالنسبه له والتفرد باتخاذ
القرار من جانب وهو يراهن ايضا على الشارع
اليميني داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي الشارع
اليميني الذي يتمثل في الائتلاف الحكومي
هو ما زال يشكل الحاضنه والقاعده الشعبيه
لهذا السبب بنيامين نتنياهو هو يذهب الى
عمليه الانفراد بعائلات الاسرى والجلوس
معهم منفرد ولا ولا ياخذ باقي اعضاء مجلس
الحرب للمناقشه في الخطط وبالتالي هو يريد
ان يبيع الوهم لعائلات الاسرى وهذا ربما
ما جعله الليله الماضيه يتحدث انه لا يوجد
هناك اطروحات قدمت لنا بينما في قبل ذلك
بيوم او يومين تحدث عن الشروط التي تضعها
حركه حماس لاي صفقه تبادل وبالتالي هو
يناقض نفسه لكنه يريد ان ان يقدم معلومات
مضلله ولهذا السبب هو يسمى داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي الكذاب ابن الكذاب لانه هو يس
سوق اكاذيب ويريد ان ان يذهب الى اقناع
المجتمع الاسرائيلي الداخلي بشكل او اخر
الى انه ما زال هناك متسع من الوقت للحديث
عن امكانيه الذهاب الى اي صفقات مستقبليه
هذا من جانب الجانب الاخر ايضا هو يريد ان
يشرك الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
التحديات التي تواجه في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط بنيامين نتنياهو لا يريد ان يكون
هو من يتحمل اي محطه من محطات الفشل التي
ستتعلق في مستقبل اسرائيل اولا في الشرق
الاو
وثانيا في اي في اي ما يتعلق في مستقبل
العلاقه الامريكيه الاسرائيليه بنيامين
نتنياهو يدرك ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هي معنيه في دعم اسرائيل للحظه
الاخيره وبالتالي هو يريد ان يستثمر هذا
الدعم الشامل لمصالح الذاتيه